that's for you
even mark's boy
that's got his kids up his nuts are
bigger than mine
rocking it holy sh
so this is a sack and then in there is
where they will settle into my nephew
had a second yo there's nothing right
here when he comes out we're gonna go
clubbing
we're gonna take him clubbing and use
them as a magnet to pull chicks
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
codes
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi
hey everybody this is producer grant
here just a reminder if you like the
show if you're enjoying the show please
like comment subscribe on any platform
you're checking it out on whether that's
on youtube whether that's apple podcast
spotify anything any engagement that we
have really really helps we all serve
the almighty algorithm these days and
any amount that you sort of interact
with the show in any way just really
helps us out helps us get cooler guests
for the show helps raise the profile for
the show helps give us more content for
you guys to enjoy so thanks again for
checking it out and please enjoy the
episode
needless to say
our guests
will not be having beer
sadly but in the old days
women
so
in the comedy days i was in las vegas in
the 90s
a harris
and there was a woman who was expecting
a child
latina
at the bar drinking a goblet of wine
and as we were having our cranberry
vodka cranberries i could not
stop looking at the fact that this woman
was expecting a child and in her into
her third goblet of red wine
what trimester was she in
it was
i would say it wasn't her child
i said are you pregnant and drinking and
she said it's not yours
there you go
you know i just made a goblet i made a
comment to my wife
uh just a couple of days ago i said back
in the day when you were pregnant i said
i don't remember people telling you
don't drink she wasn't drinking
she said well they didn't say it because
i wasn't bothered
no what you're saying yeah no why she
said wait a minute but you're but listen
i'm gonna say something right now
then we'll introduce our guest when you
first came in here you threw caution to
the wind you had a big laugh
you probably were like 70 pounds heavier
you didn't have a [ __ ] cane
and you loved it you were laughing and
then all of a sudden now that we know
more about you when something gets a
little bit too close to being married
you're like i can't
i could or not
like like almost like they're monitoring
you yeah
she doesn't even listen to [ __ ]
my wife doesn't even listen to this [ __ ]
how do you think he stayed married for
50 years
i don't know
i i i was almost saying have you noticed
the difference
in gail yeah
i mean you know you pick and choose
battles that's my more normal number no
no i'm not
i'm not more mom
if it's funny i laugh even she didn't
even
blame it on me
introduce our guests all right joining
us
uh joining us on the podcast today we
have liz iacouzi comedian uh current
podcaster host of was i in a cult
podcast
as well as self-described uh one
pregnant ass lady
welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me what is it what
does it feel like to be pregnant
your hormones change
when when when and when i was pregnant i
was working with bill ingle
and billingball and i were co-headlining
and ningbo said has anne
has just started crying for no reason
and i said no
and i went home and i said to anne
billingvale asked me if you started
crying for no reason and she goes no i
have the next day and the days after
that she would cry for no reason
did my
uh
change did you change her you're talking
about her
your hormones
no no you i thought you said the male
hormones
you've changed male hormones change more
than the women with your comic cons and
crime world
conventions
but that's all right
think of like everything you are and
then think of something sucking
everything
out of that did you know before you know
like do women know
that guys we're like
i didn't use a condom i think i'm okay
but do
you
do women know can you feel like you're
like oh my god
well there's a month that you for me i
had no idea
and it was my birthday month
yeah so
i was having it's a big it's a big thing
because
yeah the next i mean like us
you know if we're tired we can go to
sleep and wake up and be refreshed when
you're pregnant your hormones your
hormones change your body changes you
can't sleep the same way you have to pee
all the time you have to be careful
where you go and right it's it's got to
be oh and every step of the way
everything something new and for me it's
my first so i'm i've no idea what's
taking over my body well god bless you
good for you
but yeah i didn't know for a month or
seven weeks six weeks
and i just couldn't get out of bed
october
late october
couldn't get out of bed
and i was like did you think it was good
i thought it was coming that was cold i
love that
a little bit next day couldn't get out
of bed i was like oh [ __ ] i got covered
and
took the test
not covered so i was like uh what
autoimmune disorder do i have
let's go down the train the chain of
autoimmune disorders and that's the way
you felt like that's what i thought
because it was just a weird feeling
it it just i had never felt it before in
this way
and it was the same and
and um
then i said
what if i'm pregnant but that's
impossible but you know what if i'm
pregnant not impos obviously
but but but i didn't i wasn't ex i
you
it was it wasn't the plan but it wasn't
in the exact it came a little time frame
correct yeah yeah
so
that's because is there a right time or
wrong time to make love no no i know i
don't know you're in it let me say this
i don't truly in my heart of hearts oh
here comes finally something
i don't believe there's anything
prettier
than a pregnant lady that takes care of
herself
and you look beautiful versus versus one
that what that that walks around with no
shoe laces on her feet that's it yeah my
wife was a beautiful pregnant lady well
the one perk of my pregnancy so far is
my leg hair has disappeared
where'd it go i have no
i have no idea sometimes you get hairier
sometimes how about that
that you gotta prank the laying hairs
like where'd it go
it's gone three times i've shaved in the
last however months
and uh as and as you have gone
on uh uh and growing
you do you know
do you know the sex or he's a boy
because it's ca you know there's you
know there's people did somebody did
someone see you and say
it's a boy or does somebody say yeah it
was it was a psychic no it's just not a
friend or some somebody
people always say like when they see me
they're like oh you're carrying a boy
i can tell because it's all for facing
forward yep
but literally those are like people who
are
moms with nothing better to understand
than analyze what oh no apparently boys
grow this way girls grow this way i had
my first two were girls my last one was
a boy did you did you know back in the
day i wonder when they started telling
people when did they start telling me we
found out really early 10 weeks you can
find you guys wanted to know
yeah i think so i just you know i was
thinking i was thinking about it and i
said you know i do i wanna i know i i
didn't know with the first two and my
third one my my dad told me
because i had six sisters no brothers
yeah my dad told me says mujo look
if this one's another girl
count your blessings because i already
announced to the family this is at
number three no more
he says count your blessing because
girls will always come back and take
care of their fathers
boys
have to take care of their own families
they go to their own family here's what
i heard and then
if you have them if you have a boy
i'll pay for the mariachis
and then we had a boy
pay for mariachis
got the at you there so since you're
having a boy we'd like to pay for your
money thank you
that the shower or when should we hire
him uh yeah coming up when i
announced him
that day he was already he was already
out he was already out and put him in a
little mariachi outfit
and i already put his [ __ ] probably
worth it now they came in well but you
have them at alvera street right there
right montebello
so you already so you put them in a
little uniform yeah
don't put your luck here in that little
uniform
let them be in the diaper
i'm looking it wouldn't be a mariachi
outfit the the uh
here's what i heard
when you have a boy you only have to
worry about one dick and when you have a
girl you have to worry about millions of
them
that's true
because you don't want anybody banging
your
you know how's that worked out for you
it's uh you know it's
coming in
you know because you know mine's on
tick-tock and all the things there's
like there's like cleavage you're just
like really
that does it
it's your little girl you talk to her
about that you're like let's let's have
a chat about yourself i saw her on tick
tock and it looked like she was driving
and on
doing a video so i said please don't
drive and and she said oh that was my
friend okay that's different but you're
still in the car you'll be all right
um but yeah when you have a child
everything everything bless you
everything
everything changes right
because now
before you could travel right you could
pick up and say
we're going to go do this we're going to
do that and then now when you have
because you don't want to leave them
alone for
at least two years where you can't trust
you don't trust all of a sudden your mom
and your dad
and your family's the most loving family
in the world but would you leave your
kid with them no you know yeah we're
good no i really there's people that
have kids that are five years old who
have never had a babysitter like
somebody always stays with a kid
now as i get older
the only one i worry about now is the
dog
you know who's going to take care of the
dog in the family
other than that the kids are probably
that dog by the way yeah about six years
old now february to turn six yeah got
him as a stray he's been with us for a
year they said he was five years old we
found him
so he's six years old now do you know
what i saw a dog being rescued and they
cut his hair and blow-dried it and
conditioned it
and i didn't get my hair blow-dried in
conditions i was probably like [ __ ]
17.
this dog was laying in the street they
gave they hooked up cut his toenails
they did the whole thing yeah um
what um
uh the are you married
no okay
because you got that you you
it doesn't
[Laughter]
right
i haven't done it in a in a couple years
oh do you miss it
i do i figure now is the time all the
you know go on stage when you're
pregnant but when you're all if you go
on and say to your prayer and talk about
being pregnant but do it in a way
where i think that's
where i think the
the real you can you can mine like the
goals because you know things are going
to happen to you that have happened to a
lot of other women but yet
they haven't happened to some women
right and that's a good place to to live
in right you know where you can have a
perspective of
telling people that can relate but also
that's what you have to look forward to
yeah
yeah some women just love
being pregnant i
yeah which i don't know i appreciate it
but it's but i don't know how
you're you're not you you have no
ownership over anything you are not
your body
or anything or your brain
or your energy yeah and then you really
it's like storage until it's ready to
come out and then it grows and then you
go and then they say
you know you want to see it and you look
and then it starts to move
yep and then it presses against your
bladder and then you pee
all the time and then you walk around
with a big gallon of water a gallon of
water and it's still not enough water no
never enough water and uh
are you nervous about about the
the deli yeah so
that's
yeah you don't think about that when you
get pregnant
from the time that i was a kid
and i would see women who were pregnant
i always wondered if they were
afraid of giving birth they had no
choice
but
if you don't have a child and you're in
there and you go to the le mans i don't
have i don't know what they do now but
you're breathing
they don't do lamar's anymore i don't i
don't know that's what i but anyway but
whatever it's like a boxer boxing his
first fight like no one can tell you
what it's like until you get in the ring
and go [ __ ] that shit's [ __ ] hard i
got tired they told me to keep breathing
and it's
and some women it it's easy and some
women it's it's not and you don't you
don't know you don't know i didn't make
you more nervous did i no
no but but but you do think about it
yeah and i think the closer you know
you get to be when the water breaks and
it's on man once the water breaks you
can't be like i mean if you're having
contractions you could be like well hey
we're in a movie theater you'll be all
right but when the water breaks
it that's when the it's like
it's you're on the clock my first one
she was oh my god take me kill me i hate
to you know she was in a lot of pain
went through a couple of days i was in
the police academy at that time
and so we got through the first one
the second one i drove her to the
hospital
and she was starting to get excited she
was starting not excited about panicking
yeah you know she's concerned we got we
got to the emergency room door i
remember she stepped out of my chevy
pickup and her water broke
right there and she started oh my god
gil i just broke i and all like all i
want to do is keep her calm so i just
looked and i said you [ __ ] pig
how could you do get that way man you
know i'll do this god damn it in the end
and then i just i just pearl
i said you know they see this stuff all
the time it's a hospital you're pregnant
natural so i just want to get her calm
she went in there
had the baby and you mentioned lamas so
i'm saying okay i'm in there with you
okay breathe breathe free pant pat pat
she's telling me no you got it wrong
fool you got it wrong because i was
telling the wrong stuff i never made it
to the lamont school because you were
the police guy
no no this was
pull over and then she tells me spread
them
after i had remembered in the old days
you just have this guy pull around a
pony and take pictures on top of the
pony so the guy
the guy had raped me
with my first kid i told her don't ever
allow that man to put my kid on his
horse again don't ever wait me raped you
well money-wise
money-wise so i thought you picked you
up and put the devil
in the hospital she's getting ready to
have the baby she says do you love me i
said yes i love you yes i love you she
says okay
i had the guy come around we bought
pictures again
just like i love lucy
in that time she decided to be when
she's not
my sister put her up and says how am i
going to tell my husband my sister said
tell him when you're pregnant again he
can't get pissed off then so she said do
you love me i said yes i love you he
says okay i bought the biggest put the
kids on the horse again that's hilarious
did they do that lucy yeah they
[ __ ] that was good do you know that we
would entrust our children to a guy with
a mullet walking around with a donkey
[ __ ] painted black
with a seat with a cowboy hat and you
didn't know where he came from or
whether he'd return
my third kid's born
he's in the hospital
i go visit her
the day after he's born i go go to the
hospital i said hey do you love me she
says yes i said do you really love me
[ __ ] yes okay good i wrecked the truck
last night
that's good that's we got even so so
picking the right doctor yeah
who who recommended your doctor so is
that okay we talk about this oh yeah
full-on let's ask ask me anything yeah
and then we'll get to that but but but
picking the right did you have all the
same doctor for all the kids first talk
no first stalker was a family doctor
second doctor was kaiser
second anthem with kaiser
random yeah then i stopped then i dumped
geyser after that
but the first time they were born in the
hospital or outside yes in okay because
kaiser i might probably shouldn't say
nothing about kaiser i'm sure they're
elijah i mean well allegedly people
could be born outside allegedly
ah the delivery room the light's better
outside
um
but we had uh
i only have one daughter
but we had a great
and had a great doctor
and weeks before mine was going to be
born the dude goes i'm going away and i
won't be here
when you have the baby and he
recommended another doctor did they do
that they did i hear that all the time
whoa my doctor's having a second kid
like two months after me i was like whoa
good timing yeah okay that'll sync up
but you know but you know but you know
that and then you got a random doctor
for the delivery is that uh
that's not a move though isn't it is it
a move they put in no i just think it
happens and it's because the doctor that
she had was not the doctor she was
familiar with and
she had struggled during labor and
and uh
oh excuse me and
you know
damage where i think
if you had your person that'd been with
you for the whole nine months
and i don't know i hope that's not
something that they do but yeah that
sucks because you've been going to the
person from day one all of a sudden the
weeks before that hey i'm not going to
be i'm going to be in morocco
you know yeah yeah who how did you
recommend uh
i actually um had this doctor before i
got pregnant
i had like a surgery i needed and so
he's he's been with me okay good on a
journey already so
and when is your delivery day um end of
may may 29th
have you had the shower yet
no you want to come
if i'm running i want to send my aunties
where did you uh uh tower is april 23rd
that's my birthday it is yeah then you
should come [ __ ] i'll be in atlanta it's
not in atlanta is it
that'd be even crazier
so uh um but i i would like to uh um
know when the child was born and senate
uh president i love when babies are born
okay
when we were coming up if you saw
something that looked like like a
[ __ ] beginning of a dust storm they
go it's a boy you know they're right
right now you can see features oh yeah
you can see everything when where r is
right it was just [ __ ] nothing you
could see nothing no
i never saw anything any of my kids
yeah
yeah i think that's why a lot of times
you just let's see if you have it yeah
do you mind yeah no
now they have those crazy like almost 3d
looking pictures they can do i don't
know if that's what you've got okay yeah
you know when
when we first went
and it was validated that
she was and was pregnant there was a
blinking light that's the heart
and
and
when my my hand like three months to go
i said in there i said well hey can we
pull her out and play with her and put
her back in ah you know and they said oh
you gotta wait three months and three
months seem like
the [ __ ] longest in the world
26 years later
here we go and the three months to me
seemed that's for you
even mark's boy
that's got his kids his nuts are bigger
than mine
you're rocking it holys
so there's a sack and then in there is
where they will settle into my nephew
had a sec
right here when he comes out we're gonna
go clubbing
we're gonna take them clubbing and use
them as a magnet to pull chicks
because he's got some
those are some balls right there
they look like a catamaran
like the dick and then the other uh you
see the penis too right damn yeah yeah
hard to avoid
listen excellent even though he's not in
the world i'm embarrassed
was gonna be born with a big dick i
might have become a different person
[Laughter]
you know something there's something too
this is how alien he looks
you can see his face his hand is by his
like this oh that's more that real
thing yeah that's so crazy i mean that
is just incredible not crazy
look at that
oh wow
sculpted out of clay
that's some [ __ ] like mine hunter
they're like they put that [ __ ] up on it
could be me it could be you
and their heads are um
soft i think right yeah like soft yeah
they even got like a little hole at the
start don't they their brain doesn't
congeal till
much later you know when mine was born
at cedars and i went with her down the
hall walking downhill and
they were cleaning her and to see a
human head like shift
and because she's just
his uh were you in there when they were
it's wow man
and knowing that i might have said can
we
pull a little bit a little bit flat on
the back
like a filter out with the picture like
just because you could see it you could
see it like almost like a water balloon
like like shift yeah yeah yeah
very exciting though i don't remember
that stuff i think that i'm very were
you in the room when you're a miracle
child because we had a little bit of uh
what were you saying oh you yeah you
heard we had a little bit of a scare in
the beginning so
he survived awesome yeah
yeah you know i don't think that
there's anything in your life that
you will have happened to you were
spontaneously you will feel the emotion
of seeing that
boy come out yeah
oh
i cried a lot as a kid but i never cried
spontaneous right until i saw mine for
the first time
yeah and and
when
you don't have kids i was watching 60
minutes and they said when you don't
have kids you don't think of people who
have kids or
you know have something happen to a kid
until you're a parent and then you worry
about everybody else's kids and it's
true like if you don't have any
reference right and you see a kid that's
like hey are you okay he said i lost my
mom you know where you before you and
you become that
and
was went way beyond my wife was like
like a karen before they were karen's
right
and i would be like and
that strap is not on in the in the baby
bridge yarn is your baby's gonna fall
and [ __ ] just you know
everything was her her issue yeah
so so um
and
you will be born in los angeles
yes it's cedars ah
very good that's what that's what i do
i'm glad i'm not going wrong
and i go to cedars now by the way uh
yeah and and as uh
and as uh um
as a couple
um
when you go and get the updates it it
gets more exciting now
oh yeah
yeah and getting through all those first
tests or the you know
they tested 20 weeks 16 weeks 20 weeks
and then
because they can test for everything now
you know
i'm glad that they didn't have that when
we were being born where they could tell
you i think my grandmother would have
said you know what hey pull up look keep
them
i thought i would have said
frida you should no let's go eat
i think because i think
i i would say that you know now all the
kids are tested and when we were growing
up you just looked different one day
there we go come over here
you don't have [ __ ] eyelids you're
like i wasn't bored without them i never
know okay go ahead your eyes don't dry
up
like you you one day you look different
to them right and then they find out
you're a pigeon toad or you know you
were left-handed right but not like now
the whole gamut of of of tests yeah yeah
congratulations yeah so and and he's
passed all the tests yeah
all right is there do people do women
still crave like like
um
yeah
yeah mine has been really strange i'm
eating like a 14 year old teenage boy
i know and you just feel it right like i
did how does it what what first of all
what what are the cravings well in the
beginning i was very sick like just
nauseous
never threw up just like imagine your
worst hangover all day long
all day long for like
17 weeks
so
back then it was mac and cheese and a
special kind or from some place um
like i i wanted all the original
flavoring like craft or just just you
know like let's take it back to what i
eat but did you like craft growing up
yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah
but then i wanted to get some protein in
my diet so i like tried some of those
fancy mac and cheeses
yeah it was so good they were okay they
were they were okay but craft yeah
the original you know there's something
to
i like the homemade stuff
i like that yeah the homemade stuff is
good the little noodles the craft little
noodles i'm not sure what they are but
it could be part of that wall right
there but
peanut butter and jelly was a big one
yeah
jelly or grape
um
it was more like a berry yeah like i
like raspberry yeah like a blackberry
blackberry oh [ __ ] blackberry yeah
i think if you're into blackberry and
peanut butter then you are pregnant
because that's like that's that's a
total crazy very weird and in the middle
of the night any of that stuff like but
elvis would go get peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches in denver and he was in
memphis that was drugs right
yeah but in the middle of the night do
you say like oh you got to go get me if
i no i don't i don't like need a
hamburger in the middle night but i will
do like cinnamon toast crunch
cereal okay cereal and the weirdest
craving recently has been oranges i'll
have like six oranges a day
that's like the vitamins are good and
juicy i love them yeah i really have
right
also did the doctor say that's too much
sugar or
they tested me for gestational diabetes
and i was good okay remember when when
they would say you don't have a glass of
orange juice in the morning but there's
a lot of sugar in it
yeah nobody's thought about i know the
sugar over i've been going more for the
sweets than the savory way more than i
do in my real life
way more um
seafood or anything like that like no do
you eat breakfast at night
yeah i love breakfast
if you could eat something at night for
breakfast what would it be what would it
be
it's only every stephen las vegas
oh
what'd you eat
sausage eggs sausage and hash browns
yeah
sourdough chocolate wrong
true
yeah any kind of egg scramble egg bacon
mushroom pepper uh frosted flakes
in a big ass bowl yes with a lot of milk
do you add a banana yes yes and i cut it
with a knife on my ground without a
spoon yeah my grandmother told me how to
cut that knife it's not a major trick or
anything you made it seem like he was
teaching me how to walk this out
that's awesome yeah but and when you
grow up i think when you grow up poor i
don't think you have to be pregnant but
you could have
a lot of times we had breakfast for
dinner
growing up when i grew up
honestly i don't remember eating
breakfast
yeah i really don't just went straight
for lunch
yeah at school well you're done probably
where that was your dad got working and
my dad was gone working my mom was gone
working when i became old enough i had
two younger sisters
my sister reminds me i used to make them
breakfast
and she said get mad at me because i'd
make her eat raw pancakes
you're supposed to be like that eat them
[Laughter]
also you were ahead of your time yeah
yeah uh siblings
two i'm the oldest
would uh
would they make you carry on adult
duties as a child
like
you know they they how they did that
like watch your brother and sister or
watch your brothers or you got to be
like you can't go because you have to
watch your brothers
uh where did you grow up here uh no i
grew up in chicago
in evanston the greatest place in the
world and and
yeah chicago will
it's a good you have a good background
when you come from chicago i think yeah
working-class people they don't favor
anyone
and they used to be the way real people
used to be right they were honest and
they were tough and they worked hard and
they weren't
when i was uh started i went to a cubs
game and i was working at the funny firm
in the early 90s and i'm sitting down in
the bar on the way way back i couldn't
get a couch i walked
there's a guy sitting next to me and he
looks like he's staring at me and he
goes
are you a comedian i said yeah
you're not bad
you're not good
no you're not bad
and i said bro man thank you
and that is right that is where now
you're going to tell kids everything
they want to hear yeah he said i saw you
you're not great you're not bad
and
and that's
under what under what form of
childhood are you going to raise are you
are you a helicopter parent no which
they call them right yeah yeah yeah um
what what what kind of parent should i
be
what kind of parent are you george what
is it what is it a helicopter parent
where they hover over the cover
yeah way too involved
have you guys talked about that i mean
you want to make sure they're safe but
not
to where you're over overly
yes but i also think i doubt i don't
want i don't want like we're not best
friends
right like i'm your p i'm your mom
come on because i see all these people
that's good stuff wanting to be your
best friend don't be your best friend
and it [ __ ] the kids up i mean i have
friends who have mom parents like that
and it's not what they wanted it's not
what they needed
you know totally kids
go get a friend you can have a best
friend that's great i'm your mom okay
what's the number again 818 533 okay
and you know what i don't think i've
ever heard a woman say
i'm not going to be that type of parent
it's
how about when we were growing up and
you saw boys that were emasculated
at a young age already they were they
were already like [ __ ] at like seven
like they couldn't walk home and they
couldn't be alone and they cried if you
[ __ ]
wet them with a whole thing my best
friend
i could still hear his mother today and
everybody's deceased but i can still
hear today
if you don't
do what i say wait till your father gets
home tonight
mister
because i'm not wearing it i'm going to
school that's my best friend we're going
walking together and i'm not wearing a
jacket
we don't need a jacket he doesn't want
her i told you to wear a jacket mister
you're not wait till your father comes
home tonight
and
why did if she felt that strong why
didn't she just beat the [ __ ] out of him
then
that's what she said you want to make
one the good person that won the bad one
yeah good cop bad cop but i like i mean
i mean listen
i was doing a show saturday and i was
talking about people who have kids that
have food that can't touch right and
where it came from and there's a lady
a
rather young lady
and she says i have a daughter that
can't eat if the food touches
and i said well how old is she say
[ __ ] 30
i mean come on
i mean
do you i don't let her go i don't hungry
then but what what what is it though at
what point did kids say like i
i don't like this play i don't like that
right yeah right and and and and why was
that like then why was the follow-up to
that like okay cool yeah fine don't
don't eat it no
so i just i looked it up apparently
there's a term for it it's
tactilophobia
what rheumatolophobia
when you don't like your foods to touch
and it's considered and it comes in
varying levels of severity and is
believed to be a very mild form of ocd
yeah so um
because that's what happened that's what
with kids friends i would say you have
to make sure that the friends are oak
are okay right because
you know um
if they with mine i would say
if they see something they can't unsee
it so you want to make sure that
that whoever their friends were weren't
going on the computer at their house
because we had filters on the computer
at
at our house right and that's that's
that's the issue no for sure it kills me
right now i got two of my younger
grandkids they get to choose what they
want to eat
and
someone talks
you know my grandmother's that's a big
thing you know my grandmother would make
me choose she said you could have that
or you can eat [ __ ] those are the two
choices um
i tell my kids
i tell the grandkids they don't
understand i said
come here
that's what you don't want mom not
around
your partner
do you have the same beliefs um
in child rearing yes and he has a
13 year old okay so
that's cool i think i've been able to
observe you got a bit of a babysitter
which is good too which is good too
because uh um
would you
i know i can't see who was somebody the
two people were very
uh they were known and they were dating
and they were very much in love
and they could not agree on how to raise
the child and they broke up right they
didn't have a kid but they said what are
your views on on how to raise a child
and they were very very different and
they couldn't agree and they shook up
wow before even having a baby i could
see it i really can't but
would would that be an issue do you
think of uh or would you say well work
it out but if someone was adamant about
god i mean yeah i mean it was if it was
a huge difference than what i envisioned
yeah i've seen my older sisters go
through it and what and what are they
what are the issues they ended up in
divorce
because one was too easy or one didn't
want this and don't tell my kids what to
do and this is it
and one was wrong and one was right
in my opinion
and
he left
good move
the wrong and right thing is uh
and also if you have a
mother or
uh in-law or someone who has
more of where they think they're right
all the time they would say i wouldn't
let her do that if i were you i wouldn't
let him do that but it's not your child
and then that's why it goes up like
like a powder cake
are you looking forward to it
hey this is the best time right now
incubation is the best time
and you know and and also
the thing when you realize when you're
when you're leaving with the baby is in
the car seat because i don't have the
car seat is that there's no manual
there's no
there's only what you've prepared for
and then you get home and it gets
colicky and it cries for seven days in a
row and both you and your partner are
ready to [ __ ] throw each other out
the window
and it's colic and it just happens where
they don't stop crying on the job
training yeah
mine would then you know we really in an
apartment here and i would get up in the
and would go to the baby and i would go
to the kitchen and get the milk and
you know
it would be 40 seconds but and we'd be
like
hurry up and he'd be like 30 2 31. and
she goes come on you'll be screaming
and
it was it was so in the middle of the
night that i would forget to put the
[ __ ] bottle in i would close the
microwave and set it for 40 seconds and
then turn it on and i would leave the
bottle of milk on the counter and you
look at the thing
that was so tight i was so tired
yeah but it's exciting congratulations
thank you we want to see a picture we
want to be uncles i will and we're good
and we're going to send a mexican
blanket because you know and all kids
born now should have a some culture
exactly i agree yeah i do think though
um
there's some responsibility as a woman
raising a man a boy
oh
you know i like that yeah
i think i think a lot of you know a lot
of people blame
you know what what if you want to like
put some quotes around like toxic
masculinity or whatever i may say
something controversial no that's what i
say we love country but um
i think a lot of it comes from the
mothering of boys
every boy needs a father obviously right
but uh
i'm gonna say
that i didn't i never knew my father my
father took off and
um
all the guys i grew up with had fathers
and i said
in elementary school
every boy needs a father and i was like
12. 12 year olds shouldn't say that yeah
but father's day and and having my
grandmother it's all very difficult so
yes speak on that because i think you're
you're most definitely three three
children
two girls and a boy the last one was a
boy he's now 44 years old
[Music]
every boy needs a father but every girl
needs a father oh well yes
they all need
well what we're saying is
and and and my son
turned out to be nothing like his father
right
that doesn't mean i love him love him i
wouldn't say that i love him he's got
the biggest heart in the world he's a
great son says he's not like you he's
not like well because i'm heterosexual
he's gay okay it doesn't mean a damn
thing i love him
to death we talk to each other every day
i wouldn't trade him for the world you
only talk one time a day
uh sometimes okay so so
um
thanks aaron
you're the only one there but can we no
let's let's go back to that but i want
to i want to talk about what you what
you were saying because i agree
well yeah i just you know and
watching my mom you know i have a sister
and a brother and watching how she sort
of
raised my brother versus us
i think there's sometimes a bit of a
coddling that happens with moms and sons
and sort of like oh that's fine you're
you're so cute you do what you do and
like
and it it doesn't propel the boy
into society in a way
that is actually
if we're to believe the way that we're
raised that the man is the
is the keeper of the house
what you're saying is what we heard
growing up where
the boy was 15
and the girl was 13 and she would say
make your brother breakfast paint the
house and keep your eye on him and he
did nothing correct and that's where i
think in in where we grew up the girls
were like i mean listen man they should
not have chores or take care of somebody
who's older than them just because of
what uh uh they however somebody was
raised right
yeah six sisters paint thousands you
have no brothers
wow
two younger than me
the four older didn't take care of me
i took care of the two younger ones
and i would cook for them i would do
everything for them but that's rare now
i don't know because i didn't limit
anybody else's house
so the other four like they didn't
two of them got married earlier you know
they were they got the [ __ ] out so they
would have come out yeah
and but
uh the others were just
and then
nobody i wasn't uh
spoiled until i went into the army
when i went to the army then i came back
then i became spoiled listen if you have
to go to vietnam to feel spoiled
you know your home your home life is
like
can you imagine you go to vietnam you're
in a helicopter going listen man it's
[ __ ] awesome you just step out from
you know what i'm saying but you know
what i'm saying like it's like so i
became spoiled with a family then the
iron fist is not the way to get it done
either no or not listening to somebody
when they have something to say shut up
they shut up and i love them today yeah
you know we're all
my family's very very close
and my two daughters that are older and
my
my son were all very very close
he
let me ask a question
in if you could go back
and be honest don't worry about your
wife listening i'm not going to be oh
yeah i don't even know what you like
whether your wife's listening or not
you've made me hate her now
i love her
would you have wanted your sisters to be
more
caring of you no
okay no it was find the way it was
it's hard to say something that's that's
it it was fine it was fine the way it
was because they were gone
and then you took you took the part that
they probably should have had as older
they got married and got out yeah yeah
so for the most part three of them got
got married got out one
stood there a while longer
but
it was just a family you were saying you
know one tv in one room one yeah we only
had one tv
you know so it would be okay you get a
half hour you get a half hour and it'd
be my half hour and then they'd start
screaming mom he just wants to watch
sports none of us want to watch sports
okay camilo cabron so i'd have to change
from did you ever have to change your tv
with players yeah
you're too young for them yeah that's
right well what happened when you when
you guys were growing up and you were
having a feeling or you were
emotional about something or a girl
broke your heart or something happened
at school or a bully punch you in the
face
what did you do how did you deal with
that i i dealt with it with my friends
you know the guys on the block we shared
everything that became the guys on the
block
became my family
not this family but they became a family
because at 17 a cop took me home and
said
told my parents to get him off the
streets he'll end up dead or in prison
so at 17 they signed for me and i went
in but i mean it was the guys on the
block became my family and you felt that
you felt safe enough to
be open and yes for them almost
assuredly
we all shared stuff
uh
uh of the the guy that uh i named my
first show the character ernie
i knew him before i was even in first
grade passed away like
three weeks ago yeah so my first friend
my first friend passed away
so yesterday we had the memorial and um
he had a family like he had sisters and
brothers and mother and father and i
didn't my grandparents raised me and my
grandfather wasn't my biological
grandfather my mom
mom was my grandmother
and when you think about how easy it
could have been for him to neglect
me to not call me or not include me
you think about how great this guy was
that he didn't turn his back on me when
he knew i didn't have many friends and
that he stayed with me and would say hey
let's go do this let's go do that let's
go do that when at home he had way more
than i ever had i never knew my father
my mother didn't raise me and you know
toward the end of his life we weren't as
close but you know what
that didn't matter as much as how
important he was in the beginning of of
my life
like i couldn't remember when i didn't
know him
and
to say goodbye is a is like a
really really really tough thing you
know especially when you realize that
all the things that i like golf playing
the guitar richard pryor and
comedy all were his idea i must have
been a student before i had zero ideas
but you know um
i'm the godfather to his son too so i
you know it was step into i never had a
son
but
um
to neglect a child especially when it's
like neglecting a plant that needs water
and needs sun is the worst [ __ ] thing
that you can do to a a child right so
i think mothers that
over are
over or do too much for the boy
is really devastating to
his future relationships right you guys
are going to have friends
you know they they need mother and
father but they also need
outside connections right they really do
and i was blessed enough to go back
city of pico rivera where i grew up in i
was asked to be the keynote speaker in
an event they had
and i told them pete rivera they say it
takes a village to raise a child
pico rivera was my village
you know you go anywhere people back
then you know you mess up on the block
somebody else's parents would
you know they'd rat you out they'd kick
your ass they'd yell at you
so everything they they kept you all in
check right and it was it was the
village that kept me there and i'm
fortunate enough to have
friends today
that still remind me i went to a
celebration of life about a month ago a
lot of my old friends from the block and
it was just
as if we hadn't seen each other in years
it was great seeing everybody
and the the fact that time goes by so
fast right yes uh yeah so um what were
you going to say about the moms in the
oh
what about they over there they're too
coddling of them yeah or just
they don't allow them to be them to be
to have an independence yeah or yeah or
just sort of like
treat they're treated differently yeah
they're just
put more on a pedestal maybe than the
girls i think so um
and then on the flip side of that they
they aren't cultivating like a
well-rounded
human if a girl if you have a teenager
and the father is like she's going out
and she has a you're a [ __ ] but then
the boy
yeah
were you ever told to man up
or just be amazing my grandfather used
to tell me that men don't cry and
forever
i i've never heard that as a kid
nor did i ever say that to my son or
they said no
which means like don't be a [ __ ] right
and we heard that and what and then what
do you how did you interpret that it's
not to show emotion right to close down
right
yeah i can't believe i talked about
ernie and that did not shed a tear which
is i
remember talking about her yeah
but but i do believe that that
you know and i think it's in in the
generations and even as the generations
keep going and you think that
more women are reading books or or
however you get your information it
still kind of reverts back to being an
overbearing parent right
you know like you
is it is it is it against the books that
you
are reading versus what your mom did and
your grandmother did and her grandmother
did where it's all kind of a routine
right
my mom was tough and the [ __ ] that you
go through in the beginning of your life
almost i remember pop a video where they
would say oh this was filmed in l.a and
they go you know it's almost like you
wish your life could be like a pop-up
video so when someone says something to
you and they come up and say this [ __ ]
is going to hurt you for a long long
time that you were able to identify the
things that were going to be devastating
to you later like i was never able to
really
kind of connect with a person uh um
uh romantically because i was
just never saw a healthy relationship
and then as a comedian you become
innocuous to fear or nerves because
you're you're you're shut down already
you're like a veneer but where you know
if you had a healthy relationship you
would be something that you go i'm so
nervous because no i'm here you know
it's like i was by myself all the time
let somebody see all that what what is
your before what is your podcast uh
before we no but i think are those great
are those great points i think they're
this man
i think
i had a very very very very difficult
childhood and not but by abuse but just
being alone and being alone is the
[ __ ] worst
even if you have a guitar or watching tv
you're still [ __ ] alone and that no
kid should be alone in a house where
there's another adult in there and
they'd prefer that you sit in the room
by yourself than to come and sit next to
them and and and and take part in
something yeah that's traumatizing
that's that's pretty bad and and people
do because you know if you're looking at
your phone
or you see something on social media
where like a little boy is taking a
picture of his mom and his mom is all
sexy he's trying to pose like man
you can't you can't
she good looking mom no no no
that up higher you know i'm only two
feet tall
let's talk about your podcast uh yeah
it's called was in a cult
it's hilarious
i love the title
it is a it's a documentary style pot i i
my co-host is tyler mason and he's a doc
filmmaker
and um
i bring the comedy to this yes what
documents have has he
well is it behavior is it not about
pregnancy but is it behavioral as a as a
scope of
the way people behave or is it about
ones
the show itself is about people who have
been in cults and survived them
wow you were sheriff that's heavy stuff
yeah
it is heavy stuff but
it's uplifting it's inspiring it's not
doom and gloom
we sort of take a different approach to
call center how many anything how many
people
now you know if it's sold out even
though there's a couple of still single
tickets they call it a sellout how many
people
are considered a cult how many people do
you have to have to believe in you to be
considered a cult well you can be in a
one-on-one cult
oh
[Laughter]
you're locked in
yeah so so i first of all never heard
anybody say you could be in the cult
with just another person yeah okay so
yeah
so that's sort of what the show is doing
as well it's breaking down the
stereotypes of what constitutes a cult
and exposing
how many cults there are there are so
many cults
of um let's
give us some examples of cults uh
there's religious cults okay right we
know that yeah we have some
ones you've heard of like polygamists
mormon cults right
you've heard of scientology
um
we don't have a scientologist yet but
then we have a woman who was her mother
was her cult leader so it was a family
cult
and we
she tells that story so
which i kind of if the was the mother
mentally ill or was it just yeah
i would say well all cult leaders are
mpd narcissistic personality disorder
and then on top of it they're usually
sociopathic
jim jones yeah that's a bad combo that's
quite a combination there
yeah and um
but we have other um we have the stories
are amazing and and we're telling the
story through the individual's
experience so unlike
a lot of cold stuff you see it's focused
on the cult itself and the crazy cult
leader right this is about somebody's
journey in
during and out okay that's is there a
are there documentaries that we can
watch anywhere or are well your podcast
is how can people see like that's the
[ __ ] that's what we are going to make a
show but we haven't made it yet so right
now you can just listen to the story
okay
you know it's kind of really
man i mean and and that would fascinate
me
oh yeah but also let's think but we do
make we do make jokes and we bring
lightness to it because cults aren't all
doom and gloom which is the way it
should also which is the way it should
be right because in order to in order to
if you are attacking something somebody
will shut down but if you're making
light of it they might leave their mind
open enough to get
you to think that you know what that is
that's that is well it humanizes it
right it humanizes the experience the
guest feels seen not just like oh you
weird cult person right because we
really show that anybody is susceptible
to falling into an environment like this
and um
so that's why we have the before story
we get to really know you as a human
before you met
before you went to this presentation or
your friend took you to this coffee shop
or it's
it's
even like that yeah so run me run me
through do we have time we have that
right uh yeah we have about ten minutes
well wilbur's not here for another hour
uh the uh run me through how someone
would
take somebody to a coffee shop and then
get involved in something that would be
considered a cult so you know have you
heard of the whole nexium scandal yeah
okay yeah have you heard of nexium no
bro
that great great girl jessica jones
episode three i think on the show three
and four
um she was actually the whistleblower
she worked with the fbi for two years to
take him down
um
she's she's a badass yeah yeah she's a
badass so she got invited by
one like i'm a masseuse or masseuse or
something to like a just come to this
presentation there's and and you know
they always get you with snacks
it's always free wine and and snacks
so she just went to this event this
night um
harmless was it was it like uh is that
somebody's living room yeah
and it was just a pr it was just a
simple presentation and and was the
woman there not keith rainier nope he
wasn't there she wasn't there yet a
conduit um yep it was one of their
recruiters
and it was sort of like you know we
this is a self-help
um
space where we just help you become the
best you you can be and this is how we
do it and this is what it looks like and
then look at all these examples around
you and look at all these people and
then all the people tell their
testimonies and
um
they they position it as a class yeah as
almost like a self-help
this is how i started to
use my time more wisely
there's something called the vow on hbo
and it's i mean
two seasons or something yeah the second
season is coming and it starts with
like if we said you know we want to be a
little bit more
um
you wouldn't want to say aggressive just
savvy in business and you know you don't
know how many
times people
neglect their own self in order to put
someone else ahead and then they start
to use push the buttons and they kind of
have you
and then
it becomes where
they're almost that's i don't know
brainwashing that well that's the whole
thing we show right we show the
indoctrination process and how
manipulative and slow burning it is and
then so it's like a it's like a you put
a frog in lukewarm water and he's just
having a bath and you turn the heat on
by the time the water's boiling he
he's boiled today
and that's the analogy of getting
indoctrinated and they were in canada
they were in mexico they had people in
mexico that were in even in the
presidential families yeah and
well that's the other thing too they
recruit a lot of
powerful people rich people they
recruited a couple of of daughters who
were very high up in a alcohol family
that created you know famous alcohols
and they kind of started to write the
bill for this person right to attach
himself to the dalai lama or attach
themselves to different people where
from the outside it looked like they
paid the dalai lama a million dollars
to just sit there and the dalai lama was
on to that dalai lama and he was on
holier than that himself and he was on
tour but he got onto him though yeah
when they went to go visit him oh right
right later later he was honest right
right yeah yeah
but uh yeah when you think of the i can
say that with that but but
if you are okay but but
it can it can be it can be
like
would they where they infiltrate i'm not
infiltrate's not the right word they
start where somebody would say to you
recruit i have a new friend gil he's he
likes the same things that you like yeah
and then you go
and now you're like kind of like you're
starting to connect the dots right right
and like it it's interesting because
it's sort of full circle it goes back to
like community and how we
we crave community as humans we want
that feeling of belonging and
so they
prey on that and they exploit that in
different ways
and they make you feel like they have
what you've been missing correct
with the group hug and the clapping and
the but but is is the neck is that one
what are the top five
but you said also little ones like
amongst amongst people in neighborhoods
i'm sure probably right maybe in what in
neighborhoods and things that aren't as
big yeah exactly like um he's an hoa a
cult
he's a spooky man like it's
spooky if all of a sudden you go home
and pearl's not there or we go home and
and you're not there and all of a sudden
they come back and they're happy and
they say where were you oh we we meet
every wednesday yeah and we do this and
you think oh okay that's cool so once
you're going to be over there but then
as it progresses right it turns into
eternity and it all goes back to the
leader right that's the difference
between a cult and just a men's group is
do you have a
narcissistic sociopathic leader starting
to
dictate your
behavior your choices
do you start to doubt yourself do you
start to have to ask this person oh is
this do you think i should do this but
that person has to be
put on a pedestal so that when you meet
him you're like oh my god there he is
right and then he starts to tell you
things and you're like you know you're a
people pleaser like you just want to
please people and you're like man
and they just start to push the the
buttons and then they'll say but george
you are so brilliant and you're so funny
and you would you would be so good here
i mean i
i can see where you're lacking in some
areas and i can help you with that it's
like when they give you botox when they
say you kind of like you don't need a
lot just right here once they put it
right here yeah forget it
but but but that's but they chip away
they chip away at it yeah
and then you build you up and then a
little breakdown and then in the in that
thing we told you with the bow
where
the guy was the documentary and
filmmaker and then he meets a girl that
was an actress and they connect yeah and
then all of a sudden she starts to think
like this [ __ ] doesn't really kind of
make sense
and blows the whistle right and then the
husband
stays on this side while the wife goes
on that side right right and you're like
wow like
he's like boo you know i think you're
you're overreacting like it's not that
and and
fortunately they they they were they
worked it out yeah yeah
yeah yeah no but that's also what
happens that whole separation us versus
them
mentality there's all these through
doing this show i've become quite the
is there uh
is there a connective is there a
connective uh
thing to the country or is it regional
like is there something that connects in
california that goes through the midwest
and back to the and back east well yeah
there's there's cults that have um
headquarters all over
you know some cults are
religious cults so those have a lot of
like
a lot of the non-denominational
christian cults are have headquarters
okay or not headquarters but have
locations in any different city and have
you have you guys um
uh had people come out i'm sure you have
to but people that
monitor them you can't say yeah no we
haven't had anybody
we had um
one woman who came on who
her she was in a cult it it
it was her boss
and
it was a small
environment and she listened to our show
and she you know reached out and said i
need to tell my story i now realize what
i was wasn't just a toxic work
environment
he's a cult leader
and he
he raped her
and she went through the system to get
that and he has all these people
working
in this is in nashville
and he has people behind the scenes
so nothing ever happened
no
we never say his name
but he did reach out to us and said
i deny all claims
and then he said some and i don't drive
a ferrari it's a
car we're like
you just got accused of rape dude and
you're correcting what kind of car you
drive it's actually 2006. but but also
you know i'm talking about how
courageous
um
leah is
you you too that like that's a
that's a heavy yeah because
because you know if somebody calls you a
bad catholic or they say you know you're
you're a heathen for not going to church
they don't follow you home yeah or put a
video camera as you walk out in the
morning and start to talk to you as
you're walking to your car right
and uh allegedly some groups do so yeah
even in in that it's very courageous
because a lot of the cults we've had on
the show for the first season
i will say the leaders are
or some of them a lot of them are dead
today so that helps us
or the cult has been dismantled
or it's like jehovah's witness where
it's a whole religion you're pointing to
and
what what do the
um what did the jehovah witness believe
um that's a great question they don't
believe in education
or birthdays no birthdays they don't
believe in birthdays
they don't believe in accepting gifts
no they don't believe in christmas no
they don't believe in holidays
they've taken a part of the bible and
just interpreted it to their own liking
um but you should check out jw.org
one day it is
fascinating and terribly written
um
really okay so we are give the number
out uh eight one eight five three three
eighteen forty three there was someone
who
realized they weren't a cult and not
realize it because i think i think it's
it's it's the
and it's called grooming i don't know it
was i don't know what it was called
before
people started to groom people right
yeah yeah what was it called before like
just going along like what would
grooming be what would grooming be if
you would say that you know you were a
detective and you and if you said the
guy walked into a place like almost like
a pimp and then they had girls like what
would the what would that be called if
you
had people do things for you and then
you got them to believe that almost like
manson like they were doing something
for the good of yes
there was it was called grooming back
then even yeah
yeah
where you find somebody like
in the charles manson um
situation where like leslie van houten
is
comes from a good family in la canada
ends up at spahn ranch and charles
manson says to her your father doesn't
understand you does he
and she was like this is the first time
that i ever
had someone just really see through me
and understand me especially a man yeah
exactly that's right
especially they pry on all of that
do you think that uh we're almost are we
almost done that's fascinating
do you think that
a group of people who are
married
but also treat their spouse in one way
can be cultish
in a sense
definitely okay you know what i'm you
know what i'm saying you know what that
means i never looked at him like that
well because
there's ties between abusive
relationships and cults
yes but but
if wives were of the same mind where
they started to control their husbands
and not allow them to do certain things
which is not
it's a it's a cult
it's you're changing someone else's
behavior yeah no that's definitely
cultic behavior
100
what about those dudes that have to
pretend we're talking about that that
they've kidnapped they've been kidnapped
in order to go to a bachelor party in
las vegas right
you might be in a one-on-one call dude
you know what
i'm getting married it's like hey you
[ __ ] i'm gonna go to mcdonald's
yeah put a bag over my head take me to
vegas we'll come back and beat the [ __ ]
out of me and i'll say that they took me
yeah but but it becomes like that
doesn't it and the point of the show too
is like you get to see that the behavior
is in that you know it's not just like
those crazy robe wearing cult people
like it could be in your own home it
could be with your own
wife or husband and when
if you're if you're in a relationship
and you're not sure
in your heart of hearts that it is the
relationship to continue
that person will say to you listen
if you don't want to be here all you
have to do is say i don't want to be
here
but nobody ever says i don't want to be
here right because they're afraid right
and that's
part of it right well yeah i think a lot
of the a lot of it is people ask
questions like if you don't understand
how this stuff works they say
well why don't you just leave
and that's
right you can't just now see now you've
brought up another question
why don't they want to leave are they
afraid of the unknown
afraid of just
leaving their security
why won't they just okay as a detective
when you knew somebody had [ __ ] done
something yeah and you asked them did
you do it and they said no what did you
think
like if you said hey
you know
like they say the police never ask a
question unless they know the answer to
it they're not guessing
so you would know and you would say to
somebody are you responsible for this
and they would say no
but you knew they did why would they say
no
because
it's an irrational act that they're
trying to get away from
and it follows with rack
acts of rationality in order to get away
from it so you murder somebody that's an
irrational act
now you're acting rationally by trying
to
separate yourself from that
so that's why we expect them to say this
so the lie
an act of rationality you you don't
want to be honest with yeah well i think
also too like why why don't you ask why
don't you just leave
or why do you yeah i i just you know if
i'm if i'm that unhappy and i sit there
and say i want to leave that's what i'm
afraid to say i want to leave am i
afraid because i'm afraid of leaving
comfort you know at least i have a house
i have well there's usually it depends
on the couple or the situation obviously
but usually there's some um
you've been brainwashed to a degree and
your self-esteem has been ripped from
under you from this person
who you're in this situation with so
it's like they say the definition of a
cultic relationship is you're seeking
love
from the same person that's abusing you
right so you're constantly trying to win
this person's approval
gotcha and also at the same time you say
okay finally i feel strong today i'm
gonna leave and then that person says
yeah you can leave but you'll probably
get cancer
yeah or you can leave but you know i
know you and you you're gonna you can't
really do it on your own or they'll say
some super
yeah yeah
yeah i
and does it go bad and and i'm gonna say
that it goes back to for a man
being being treated the way that your
mother treated you and not giving you a
[ __ ] spine or you could disagree with
somebody
i'm not gonna
i'm gonna say when i was married
everything had to be right or wrong
we couldn't disagree
and i would say to ann who i love
mine's mom
why don't we just agree to disagree and
not have somebody have to be right or
wrong right and that
we could never
be in disagreement somebody had to be
right and somebody had to be wrong so
when you're not going into
her saying no you're right i am that way
i repelled and then you you get out
instead of saying when you see some
husbands that do do go way over and are
being manipulated will will will smith
slapping chris rock
i think is a manipulation
and yeah you end up at the point where
you're really at the [ __ ]
end of your rope you've walked the plank
and the only place to go is down
yeah the and all the manipulation that
you've dealt with leading up to that
point
it's just
it's like
getting untangled
sounds good to me
and there is no benefit for going along
you're just going along well
you're going along to appease you just
you've sort of lost yourself yes you
don't really get a say anymore your
opinion isn't
so
uh jaden jaden smith and willow smith
are
will smith's
children uh willow smith wrote a letter
to tupac
saying that i wish you were here because
if you were here you would make us happy
oh
i saw i saw the headline that she had
written that letter i did not know
that's what it contained uh pull the
letter open let's yeah yeah we may not
air it but
i want you to i want to get your opinion
of what you've never you've never heard
anything like it i mean from someone
maybe who was a stepfather or father
they're fighting when he's two possibly
tupac and jade jaden
jade i think maybe they were maybe
dating back in the day
but she wrote a letter to somebody who
hasn't been around in 25
almost 30 years and somebody who she
obviously she never she doesn't know she
never got over them
you got it
i mean this is it's chilling yeah
finding a cup is it does it look like it
dear tupac
yeah dear tupac i know you're alive
someplace uh i think that my mommy
really misses you can you please come
back can you come back so mommy and me
can be happy i wish you were here i
really do wow and i think it's a sad
face it looks like a scribble but love
willow
wow
that came out it's
i've talked i just yes i just saw this
started to go around that's good
articles
doesn't mean i know what's going on in
the world
that is maybe one of the most
devastating things that could ever be
written well we'll say now
will he slap himself
what do you make
i mean
that's
something to chew on
in your life in your life you would
never think
that
someone would write that to
and then publish it and publish it we're
sure that's she wrote that uh i mean
that's just what i found on this quick
google but i had seen that article and
that headline sort of going around for
the past couple days so
i wouldn't be surprised
yeah there's something
not right going on there's something
going on a little bit that's uh of what
we have spoken of yeah there's some
major
you guys can do an episode there's a lot
of stuff there yeah for sure thank you
this was awesome yeah thank you tell the
people again where to find oh sure sure
sure uh you guys can find the podcast
anywhere you get your podcast uh at was
i it's called was i in a cult i'm gonna
start uh i'm gonna be flying i'll be
not in town but i'm gonna start to i'm
gonna download those and check them out
fantastic because it's amazing yeah
that's amazing can't wait let me know
what you think
uh and you can follow us at wazinacult
on instagram
and i'm at the iacoozie
okay like jacuzzi with us have you
spoken to the nexium any of the people
from the hbo thing or um
not from the val
no but jessica no the one when i the
woman i did speak to was asked to be
unseduced
she turned it down though yeah did you
watch seduce yes you did seduces like on
the stars listen that's only four
episodes and that one gets into
all of the stuff they branded the dude
was branding women
[ __ ]
on
on their pelvic region
that's crazy like aaron
he has an atc on his hip
fascinating the girls i spoke to were
branded they they got out before that
where you put your information yeah of
course yeah branded with like a cow in
the fire on the flesh and they hold the
person down
that
you know i almost got a tattoo what
about the covent like people that were
in covents
oh yeah so when i bought my house in
those in
uh so when i bought my house in los
angeles
there was an elderly woman
who lived alone next door to me who was
in her early 90s
and then she passed away and the house
was sold immediately
and it was i put both of them on there
it was oh thank you
understood that she
was
part of a covent
of women who had never been married
and who lived in that house which was
owned by whatever
religious uh sex that they believed in
right
that's called and she was the last one
and she was the last one is she out does
she want to be on the show
damn well thanks for coming out thank
you guys this is
amazing and you didn't have to pee the
whole hour
that's awesome
how big this is look how big it is
you